depuis 40 ans le peuple vit sous le joug
d'un tyran qui lui interdit les plus
élémentaires des droits de l'homme
nous devons poursuivre la mission de
l'otan et le traduire en justice qu'il
quitte le pouvoir et après toute la
discussion est possible de voter
[Musique]
ahmad ali
mairie car le berceau originel du sida à
la générale bienvenue à new york durant
votre séjour je vous conseille vivement
de visiter lampe ailleurs state building
avant que vous l'un de vos cousins de le
rayer de la carte
[Musique]
mégane avec toi j'en ai pour mon argent
parce que le conseiller comme convenu
avec ton agent c'est quoi c'est un rugby
c'est de l'humour tu me prends pour une
serre kardashian avant toi tu as moins
de poils
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]